- Thank God I'm missing the playoffs so I can focus on research.
- Are you down and out and unsure what to ride into the playoffs?
At Chargers Auto Group,
our bandwagon is huge, and this bad boy is very empty.
- It's all electric, and it comes in dope colors.
- Not sure about budget?
- We're flexib—
- Exceeding expectations with a QB you've talked yourself into:
the Throwback Giants Bandwagon.
It can be 2008 again.
- You name it, we got it! All the bells and whistles.
- A strong defense!
- Check.
- A franchise quarterback.
- Well...
- OK, yeah, our cars are gonna break on ya.
But that's why we got a...
[Alarm blaring]
- Next One Up policy. Woo!
- That's right. We've got seemingly unlimited options.
So come on down to the Niners.
- [All:] We'll get there somehow.
- I've got three words for you: No money down!
Right, Lamar?
- I'm not selling s--t until I get my commission!
- Yo, if you didn't support us from day one, f--k off.
#NoNewFans. Wagon's not for sale.
- Yeah, she's got some miles on her, but she's as reliable as always.
And don't you ever forget that.
- I really wish you would stop asking about our safety features.
[Alarm ringing]
- What's up, sports fans?
Sure, we're out of it.
But do you really wanna go with a fancy playoff dealership?
Or do you wanna watch me lift that sedan?
- Do not, I repeat do not, come down to Arrowhead Automotive.
There's no more space on our bandwagon!
That's right, our bandwagon is full and closed,
because everyone loves us so much.